Speaker 1: You might remember we talked
one, maybe two months ago about the Republican
National Committee telling Trump, if you declare
that you're running for the presidency before the
midterms, we're not going to pay your legal fees
anymore. And this raised two interesting topics.
One was, wow, the RNC believes, maybe correctly,
that Trump declaring his candidacy now would
be bad for Republicans in November. And that
probably is true. And then the second revelation
was the RNC is paying Trump's legal fees. What's
the deal with that? And the most likely conclusion
that most of you came to, based on the people
that emailed me, is the RNC is incentivized to
pay Trump's legal fees so that he maybe keeps
himself out of some trouble. That could be even
more damaging to our candidates, our being the
Republican Party in November. But it's all very
speculative and very, very sort of nebulous.
We now have learned that the RNC is not paying
Trump's legal fees for what's going on at Mar a
Lago. And we have a number of different articles
about this. And one of them, Politico, is really
the main news outlet reporting this in an article
called Trump Adds Former Florida Solicitor General
to legal team working Mar a Lago probe a few
paragraphs in you see Trump will have to pay
on his own. A person familiar with the matter
confirmed that the RNC is not paying for Trump's
legal fees related to the FBI's investigation
and retrieval of documents at Mar a Lago.
That's a departure of sorts from the past. The
RNC has, for example, paid Trump's legal bills
involving New York Attorney General Tish James's
investigation. The committee would stop paying
Trump's legal fees should he formally declared his
candidacy a step he has hinted at but has yet to
take. So this actually has a number of different
potential implications. Number one, Trump has been
extra flipping out in public. And
a little bit later in the show,
we're going to look at Trump did a 60 post sort of
apoplectic tirade on Troth, essentially yesterday,
60 posts, including Q and on conspiracy theories.
Part of Trump being extra unhinged may be
that they're no longer paying his legal fees. And
the second element of this is this might explain
why Donald Trump is having so much trouble finding
good lawyers. They probably know the lawyers
that without the backing of the RNC for the legal
bills, they're probably never going to get paid.
And I you know, every time I've dealt with a
lawyer, they go, send me a five grand retainer
upfront and I'll start billing out of that five
grand. I'm guessing with Trump, they're having
trouble getting the getting the upfront retainer
money. But this could explain why Trump is having
trouble finding lawyers as well. And it could
be a very, very crazy eight weeks between now
and the midterms. And there is an indictment.
Watch. I mean, it's kind of a weird term because
we're likely to learn about it after the
fact. But there is now a open discussion about
more like when will the indictment happen rather
than. If, although I suggest we still wait before
we assume that that will take place. So Trump
now paying or not really, I guess we could say,
responsible for his own legal fees, but whether he
will pay them is a different issue. We will have
all of these images and pictures and videos,
including the one of the secret documents in
Trump's house on our Instagram, which you can
find at David Pakman show. Also, by the way,
if you want to see some whacky, wacky hate mail
I got. Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.